Let’s talk about what are probably the biggest protests happening anywhere in the world.
Farmers in India have been demonstrating almost non-stop for months.
They say new laws to improve agriculture are going to help big business but hurt small farmers.
The protests even got Greta Thunberg and Rihanna chiming in — and lots of Indian media telling them to butt out.
So what is it about these laws that farmers don’t like?
Why does the Indian government think the protesters have it all wrong?
And why is this about so much more than just farming?
How do we feed everyone, protect farming jobs and save the planet all at the same time?
It’s something most countries are trying to figure out.
A lot of it comes down to choosing what kind of system they want.
In some places the farming industry is driven by business. In others like the European Union governments subsidise agriculture.
That’s the juncture India’s at right now.
For a long time farming there has relied on subsidies and a whole lot of regulation.
It's one way of supporting the nearly 1.4 billion people there given that about half of them work in agriculture.
But in India farming’s been in trouble for a while.
It only accounts for one-sixth of India's GDP.
There are issues around land ownership, irrigation, corruption and unpredictable weather because of global warming.
And all that's caused a lot of suffering.
So something had to change. The government and the farmers both agree on that.
What they can’t agree on is how.
Last year the government brought in three laws to modernise the agriculture industry.
One of the changes farmers are talking about relates to who they do business with.
Most farmers have relied on state-controlled wholesale markets called “mandis”, where they are guaranteed a minimum price for their produce.
The mandis then sell to buyers like supermarkets.
But under the new laws buyers can avoid the mandis and do business directly with the farmers.
Plenty of economists and the ruling BJP party say that’s an obvious win.
But farmers and their unions are worried about being taken advantage of, that the mandi markets will eventually disappear, even though the government says that won’t happen.
And that big corporations will demand lower prices from small farmers who have little bargaining power.
There’s so much more to these laws and farmers have a bunch of other concerns.
A lot of it boils down to a lack of trust.
It hasn’t helped that the government rushed these laws through parliament last year without any real discussion.
That’s what the farmers and opposition parties say.
So they want the laws gone. And they’re sending a message.
A convoy of tractors from India’s northern states descended on the capital but they were blocked at the city’s gates.
So they set up three main campsites — and they’re huge.
Hundreds of thousands of people have been living there for weeks.
And things have gotten pretty heated.
On India’s Republic Day protesters breached the walls of the Red Fort, one of the city’s main monuments, and police confronted them there.
Police have also been closing in on the farmers’ campsites using rows of barricades and barbed wire.
But they’ve gone further than that.
And then there’s the media wars, especially after Western celebrities started commenting on the crackdown.
And Indian celebrities hit back.
So this has snowballed into something bigger than just farming.
They’re talking about people’s right to dissent, police violence, even the whole idea of democracy in India.
And some say party politics are making it all worse.
Critics of Prime Minister Narendra Modi think he’s creating business opportunities for his rich friends.
Then you’ve got the ruling party and state media blaming the protests on opposition groups.
They point to these protesters waving a Sikh flag as proof that separatists from the north are involved too.
Those laws are meant to reform the industry. But they now seem to stand in the way of any progress at all.
What’s missing is a whole lot of trust — but they have a starting point.
Pretty much everyone agrees that farming in India needs fixing.
So hopefully that was a useful primer. There is so much more in these farm laws and plenty of politics playing out.
As always check out our website aljazeera.com for the latest news and I’ll see you next week.